is how you make Filipino style spaghetti
if the spaghetti doesn't have condensed
milk then I don't want it in medium heat
add some oil onion
now we're going to cook the onions
you're gonna need bell peppers bell
peppers are essential for Filipino
spaghetti
constantly stir do not let them brown
paint your kosher salts and black pepper
we're gonna add garlic paste you can
also use fresh garlic of course
I'll set this aside in the same pan add
your ground beef
we're gonna add the veggies back the
Filipino hot dog for this recipe we're
going to use Filipino style hot dog they
look like they came out straight from a
cartoon but they're delicious now we're
going to add the tomato sauce you can
use regular tomato sauce but if you can
find this in the store I recommend using
it just make your life easier some
bouillon Cube to taste I'm gonna add
some banana ketchup this is the banana
ketchup I use we're gonna let the simmer
in low heat now to finish it off I'm
going to add a few teaspoons of
condensed milk just add creaminess and
sweetness to it